a hastily rewritten conference speech a
day early and featuring heavy criticism
of the prime minister at its heart Boris
Johnson has been found to have misled
the country this unelected Prime
Minister should now resign after days of
questions about party unity over brexit
labor united in opposition he thinks
he's above us all he's part of an elite
that disdains democracy I tell you this
I don't think he's fit to be Prime
Minister Jeremy Corbyn is under pressure
to call a vote of no confidence in the
Prime Minister but he stopped short of
doing so today and it fears it will
increase the chance of leaving the EU
without a deal this crisis with the
general election that election needs to
take place as soon as this government
threat of a disastrous No Deal is taken
off the table
despite the focus on Boris Johnson and
brexit there was policy - we will create
a new publicly owned generic drugs
manufacturers to supply cheaper
medicines to our NHS an opportunity to
rattle off some previous crowd-pleasing
announcements will mean better wages
greater security and more say putting
power in the hands of people and we will
bring rail mail water and the National
Grid into public ownership
[Applause]
here in Brighton to bring his MPs and
delegates together as Jeremy Corbyn
rounded on a prime minister under
pressure there were policy announcements
- in this hastily rear-end speech we
thought MP is hot-footed back to London
but the question is Jeremy Corbyn says
he wants to be a new type of Prime
Minister he stopped short today
to get a vote of no-confidence Boris
Johnson so when will that election come
and can he hold his party together and
sell it does the message is clear but
the timetable isn't Kate McCann Sky News